these guys have sold more than 17
million albums but we want to take you
back to when we first met 15 it started
out with Nicolas being on Broadway and
then all three of us just writing a song
together and somebody hearing a Hamre on
the band was almost called sons of Jonas
and even officially had the name j-3
before going with the Jonas Brothers
they were Boy Scouts home-schooled and
their dad was a pastor the three also
said they'd stay virgins until marriage
and famously wore purity ring's as a
reminder we're not trying to get any
message across really it was a private
decision that was made public you know
that's just something that we really
believe in and whatever
the Disney machine quickly catapulted
the Joe Broz to fame we experienced the
frenzy firsthand when Kevin Joe and Nick
came to the et set do you guys have
nicknames for each other Kay - oh yes oh
yeah the company - Nicky's mr. president
because he pretty much it will be
president in 2038 I have a lot of voters
by that time I think single dating
single same here you know being on the
road girls don't like it when you're
gone 200 days out of the year but
seriously when it came to the ladies
each of the Joe pros had no problem for
Priyanka Chopra there was Nick's first
love Miley Cyrus he then moved on to
Selena Gomez and Olivia Coco in 2015
Nick had a month-long fling with Kate
Hudson as for Joe his first crush was
his camp rock co-star Demi Lovato yeah I
was I mean I still AM Joe also dated
Taylor Swift who he dumped in a 27
second phone call he was also with gigi
hadid and look what we found three years
before Joe started dating his now wife
sophie Turner dreams show for you to be
on show I would love to be part of good
Game of Thrones and a huge fan and what
about Kevin whose real name is Paul he's
married with two daughters of course we
cannot forget to mention the brothers
glow up each one of them hits the gym
and has totally transformed their body a
big change from when we first met the
Jonas Brothers I'm a sucker for you
[Music]
[Applause]